brothers and sisters
respected guests thank you for joining
us on
our latest on our latest segment
regarding the book
we had authored by the great
and esteemed late scholar of islam
sudden even
may allah subhanahu wa have mercy upon
him and may we meet him in the hereafter
we were discussing in our previous
segment
in our previous installment in our
previous episode
we were discussing what the prophet
salallahu
would recite in which prayer we
discussed
only the first prayer and that is surat
al-fajr
excuse me and
we mentioned that ibn al-qayyam said the
general
rule and the general trend and pattern
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
is that he would recite in salat al-fajr
between the first and second raqqa
between
to 100 verses and we said of medium
length
then he gave us exact particular
examples
he said that he had recited
in one occasion in
and we discuss that in another instance
when he was traveling
just the final two chapters of the quran
and we discussed that at on one occasion
he had begun in salat al-fajr with
reciting surat al-mu'min
until he reached roughly the first third
and he began to cough and this persisted
causing him to go into the core to
compose himself to
to catch his breath
he says
[Silence]
he says and particularly
on the fajr of the day of jumu'
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would traditionally
customarily recite in the first
surat and in the second s
some scholars of of hadith and tafsir
he says and the reason that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would recite
these two chapters particularly
customarily on the fajr of
the day of jumu' is because these two
chapters when we look at their what
they are comprised of and the subjects
and topics which they touch upon
we see that both both of these chapters
discuss with an amount
a significant amount of detail the
beginning of the creation of the human
being and the world
discussing the day of resurrection
discussing the
creation of adam alaihissalam in general
discussing when
the human being will enter paradise or
the hellfire
and also discussing what
has happened generally and what
is to happen generally on the day of
jumu'
now what ibn al-qaeda is here he's
referring to a narration
in a sahih in which the prophet
sallallahu alaihi was
says the best and most superior of the
days
meaning of the week in which the sun
rises
upon is the day of jumu' the day of
friday
on that day allah created adam on that
day he entered him into paradise
on that day he was taken out of paradise
and the day of resurrection will
commence on the day of jumu' well
and so the day of jumu' is actually
very significant in our religion
and so because of these meanings we see
that
this parallels the choice of chapters
in which the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would recite customarily on the
fajr of jummah
in the narration of abdullah bin umar
with an acceptable chain of narration
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
he says that the most
beloved prayer meaning of the five daily
prayers
in all of the week and all of the days
is the prayer of fajr
the dawn prayer
on the day of jumu' friday dawn prayer
in jamaa and so the scholars of islam
derive from this narration that the most
superior of all the five prayers
in the sense of reward is
in the masjid in jamal if a person lives
in an area where there is no masjid
then jamaa with anyone who is present or
around them
even if it is your own family members
provided there's no mesjet
[Silence]
he says and likewise
it was customary for the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
in big gatherings meaning gatherings
which are exceptionally large
right such as the
prayer for eid and salat
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would often recite surat kaf
and surat al-qamr
[Silence]
surat khaf in the first sadaqah and
surat
al-qamr in the second on
in other times on jumu' and aid
in the first and second rakah he would
recite surat
al-alah in the first and second
respectively
right and unfortunately
much of this is is simply not possible
given the state
of people's customs
in going to the masjid very rarely are
people going to be
patient enough to listen to these verses
and there are a number of reasons it's
not
that the muslims somehow dislike hearing
the quran
our society has timed everything in such
a way that you have to be at this time
at this moment there's traffic people
are in a hurry to get
out of the masjid because traffic hits
at a very particular time if you live in
an urban area
and if you leave just 10 or 15 minutes
late
for work you get stuck in traffic for
hours on end
we understand there are reasons it's not
just that people are
impatient or dislike to listen to the
quran
and also in countries such as
america and so forth most people their
first language is not islam
is not arabic even the arabs
many of them who are here who listen to
the quran
who have not studied classical arabic do
not understand
a lot i don't want to say the majority
but do not
understand a lot of what is being
recited in the quran and that is a
tragedy
that is an absolute tragedy however
these reasons amongst others
cause the impatience and the brevity of
recitation that has evolved
in these days and massage it
and we don't want to speak holistically
there are massages where
people still are conditioned to
recite exactly as the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam did
and and that is fine as well
he says now we're going to discuss
what the prophet sallahu asylum would
customarily recite
during right the afternoon prayer
sometimes he would make the prayer of
particularly
[Silence]
he says and sometimes the prophet
salallahu
make it especially particularly long
right now this is a silent prayer
so each person is reciting to him or
herself
right sometimes this prayer
would be very long so it is a
essentially a very
long silent meditation over the words of
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
he said
narrates to us and this is collected by
the imam muslim
that sometimes
often yannick canada in the
would begin i mean in the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would be called he would start leading
the companions in prayer and the masjid
a person may leave medina to go to
al-baqir al-baqir is kind of on the
outskirts
of medina it's an area where people
would often go to relieve themselves
of course people didn't have luxuries
that we have
you know restrooms in your house in
every part of your house
you know so you don't have to even walk
upstairs and walk downstairs
also having running water and houses
this was not available
so a person would go all the way to
albakia
to secluded area in the outskirts of
medina where people would
relieve themselves and relieve himself
and and then come back to his house in
medina
and make wudu because that's where the
water would be
and then come to the masjid and
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
is still in the first soraka of surat
right so we're talking 20 minutes
easy the first raka or even longer
in salah right this narration has been
collected by the imam muslim
this is something that would happen
often if
if somebody did this today in most
communities
you know if the imam did this i think he
would probably finish salah and turn
around and find nobody there
okay
so
[Silence]
he says
and sometimes and often times the
prophet sallallahu alaihi
salat would recite roughly
the length of surat sajdah
or sometimes even the length of
which is pretty short right which is
kind of about what we pray with now
that's kind of the length that we're
accustomed to in these times
or surat right roughly a little less
than a page
or surat which is about a page long
we're talking about three minutes each
raka
so sometimes very long but often times
this short he says
he says and as for salah
now we're moving on to al-assad how long
would would his prayer be
if it was a long prayer for salah
it would be half as long as the longest
prayer of the
and if it is just a regular prayer not
particularly long
not particularly short it would be
the same length as salah
he says and as for salat
right this is the salah of sunset suns
after sunset
right dusk fakana had you
his custom of what he would recite
during the salah of meghrib is different
than what people are doing today now
claim is saying this when
roughly seven or eight hundred years ago
right so if nokia is in the eighth
century
after hijra he was born in the end
of the seventh century
and passed away in the middle of the
eighth century after hijab and so
he's saying it's different than people
are doing today
that was his time so how much more
different would it be today
i mean you you be the judge
is one of those prayers that would be
the longest
right he mentions
once the prophet sallallahu alaihi
sallam led
people in sighted surat al-araf
in both raqqa the first and second raka
surat
is one of the seven longest chapters of
the quran
right so it exceeds about 30 pages it's
a very long chapter
and once he recited
which is about two and a half pages it's
you know it's part of
also el morcellet which is also part of
almo fossil
which is about roughly two pages
collectively
a little less right and so
would usually be the longest prayer so
if we were to put them in order from
longest to shortest
we would start with salat al-marib
it is the shortest
he says
[Silence]
he says and as for always reciting
in shortest chapters of the quran from
to the end of the quran some scholars
say from surah al-hujura to the end of
the quran this is
this section of
the muslif is referred to as
it is the shortest usually the shortest
chapters
and they are particular to this ummah
right
and so in
only reciting from el mufasa in shortest
chapters the final chapters
this is something which marwan did
this is one of the leaders of the
muslims that came
later on after the four khulafat
and a number of things were
introduced during this time
during this era the companions were
still prevalent they were still around
they were still in relative abundance
and
a lot of
a lot of disagreement from the
companions was
expressed towards marwan and some of the
things that he started to change
right such as bringing a member
to such as
this and such as he
he had switched actually the
he had switched the eid prayer and
because the companions did not him
and so the sunnah is that a person can
listen to
it can pray salah and then
if he wishes to leave he does not have
to
listen to the khutbah and so the
companions would get up and leave
after the salah eat well marwan had
something to say and he wanted them to
hear it
so he started giving the khutba before
salah
to force them to wait for salah eat
because many of the companions and the
scholars of islam view selected to be
obligatory
upon each person and so these are some
of the things that were introduced at
that time
and one of the companions of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam who
voiced his disagreement with this
david zaydev is
one of the most knowledgeable of amongst
the companions with regards to the quran
and he is one of the
four scholars of the quran in the time
of abu bakr al-sadiq
that got together well
zaidaban thabet in the time of abu bakr
and then the four and the time of uthman
to compile the quran into one
book
is one of the scholars of andalus in the
fifth century after hijrah
and ibn abdul is one of the great
scholars of the maliki method
[Silence]
it has been collected and when we look
at all the narrations we see
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
was narrated to have recited
in salat
which is pretty long which is
fairly long
which is very short
which is pretty short and that is
something which is most of the time
and that's something that is well known
and that's something that
many places do and
he would recite in often
the short chapters so he would not
always recite the longest chapters nor
would he
always recite the shortest chapters
sometimes this and sometimes this
and all of these are well-known and
authentic
narrations narrated from a multitude of
sources
even abdulbar says
so the thing is is that
is a very important prayer and it was a
kind of a test
in the time of the prophet salallahu
so we have to understand how the work
day worked
how people's schedule were schedules
were
in the time of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
oftentimes people would wake up at dawn
they would make solatel al-fajr they
would start their day with a
long-winded prayer
with lots of
verses of the quran recited by the
prophet salallahu
and they would pray as the sun was
essentially rising so
while they are praying they are it is
pitch dark
because there's no lights in medina
there's no electricity there's no
candles
the masjid did not have lights in it for
a very long time
right and so when you go to pray
it's so dark that you don't know who's
next to you you don't know if somebody
came or didn't come
and this is why the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam says
that the most difficult two prayers for
the hypocrites is
isha and fajr the reason is because if
they don't go nobody notices
right only allah notices so it's a real
test of
faith faith that a person would go
at night to pray in jannah
even though nobody but allah would
really
would really recognize his presence
right
and so if you can imagine with me the
companions of
the elohim are making salah they're
listening to the prophet sallallahu
alaihi sallam recite these verses
and slowly
you know the light
of the break of dawn is creeping into
the masjid
and lighting up the masjid and
after they conclude their prayer often
times the companions
a very good majority of them would sit
in the masjid
until the sun rises completely
and so often times the companions of
after salat al-fajr would be concluded
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam with them
they would sit in the masjid and they
would remain in their same places
making dhikr and dua until the sun
completely rises
some of them would stand and make
solatul
others would leave to their respective
responsibilities
so some were merchants which
people who are merchants they have a
little bit different a schedule
more of an evening thing and many of
them the people of medina were farmers
and so farming takes place usually at
the break of dawn the early morning
all the way till late afternoon and so
each would go to 10 to his
responsibilities
they would gather back at the masjid at
right this is right smack in the middle
of
the time of work the work day
right it still is today and so it was
particularly
important if a person's mind is all over
the place because they kind of just left
the bustle of whatever they were doing
to come and pray
we see now why it's it is that a person
recites to himself
right because it's easy for me to
it's easy for my mind to
wander and not focus on what the imam is
reciting but if i have to recite there
has to be a level of
concentration it's more likely that i
will
focus on what i am reciting if i
recite to myself is similar
same way now when we go to salat
al-marib
people would usually go home after asur
by that time they've gone home they've
eaten whatever they come back to make
salat
right a person now is less
less distracted and so the imam now
recites
now salat and salat
are the two closest prayers they're
right on the heels of each other
right so so when the sun goes down
is when the twilight from sunset
dissipates the redness in the sky is
gone this is when solace
starts and so it's brief
and it's likely if you go home after
maghrib
and you get comfortable and the lights
are out you may not
get up for sallet you may not return to
the masjid for solatul
and so most or many at least of the
companions
would sit in the masjid and wait for
salah
isha right and so
we see that sometimes the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
very long almost as if to
you're here anyways we might as well
read a long
portion of the quran that way when we
are done
there will only be a little bit of
time left between mechrib and aisha
which would be more likely for people to
stay in the masjid
as opposed to go home and then fail to
return
and so
is the end now now it's time to go home
and go to sleep
and so salah is the shortest salah out
of all of them
out of all of the prayers of the day
salah should be
customarily the shortest right
he says
as for sallallahu
he said the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was narrated to have recited
surah 13 which is a very brief
chapter of the quran in salat
and he actually gave a time frame for
muayath
now what is what is this time frame that
he
had commanded
one of the great scholars of
the companions of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
as a matter of fact in a narration
collected by imam ahmed
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
he said the most knowledgeable
amongst my companions with regards to
that which is lawful
and that which is unlawful in the
religion of allah
and all of my ummah is
and it said that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi
is
will be resurrected on the day of
resurrection and brought forth
ahead of all of the rest of the scholars
of islam
of the ummah of the prophet muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
a stone's throw ahead of everyone else
what does this mean it's almost like
the scholars of islam will be
resurrected and
will be resurrected this is to emphasize
his knowledge and
died at the age of 34 years old
he died in the plague of amwas
which came right after the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
passed away during the time of omar in
the few years after
and so muhammad
was actually sent by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam in his final
years he was sent in his final days
and this is all part of what we're
talking about i mean we are
talking about prayer and so forth but we
want to also
get to know who these people are you
know
etc so
was sent by the prophet muhammed to
yemen
to invite the people of yemen to islam
they were christian and also there was a
large portion that were
idolaters in yemen at that time and so
he sent muaf and
as he was seeing muad off to yemen
and giving him some
advice on how to give
da'wah and how to call the people to
islam he
was on his writing
animal and the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam was walking along beside him
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam was sending
than saying perhaps when you return to
medina i won't be here
because the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam knew that he
his death was imminent and muad
understood this
and he said that he was crying on the
horse he did not want to go
the prophet salallahu wasallam sent he
went to yemen
the prophet salallahu al-islam passed
away while
was in yemen when he returned in the
time of omar
omar requested he return he came back to
medina
and he found medina to be very empty
without the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
and so he asked permission that he be
dispatched to hashem
to syria to dimash to be there
rather than be in medina without the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
because it wasn't the same anymore
right and so he went and he was given
permission by
and then the great plague of amwas
came through and barreled through that
area as prophesied by the prophet
[Arabic recitation]
and he was fell victim to that plague
now is very interesting
because the way that he would
do things is who would come
and pray salat with the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
all right he would praise allah with the
prophet salallahu
because he wants to get his prayer
you know that barakah that blessing of
praying with the prophets all the
lawyers
and then he would go back to one of the
villages of medina
where his people are waiting for him in
their masjid
and he would lead them in isha right
so he's praying salat with the prophet
salallahu sallam
then he's going to lead salatul in his
own villages
in medina his people so people would
wait for him
well love the quran a lot
and he would pray salah the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and then he would go back to his village
and lead them in
isha they've already been waiting and he
would make a
very long salah so much so that
often he would recite suratul baqarah
which would take two or three hours
right
and so this is where we have the story
of
we will get into the details of that
inshallah ta'ala in our next
episode of this great
series we ask allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
that he
shower us with wisdom and understanding
and mercy
and forgiveness and
patience
[Silence]
foreign